Couple of issues arise with respect to visitor pattern.
First off, if you think about it, the actual operation called at any
time is dependent on two things. An element such as assignment statement and
a particular visitor such as type checking. This dependency is sometimes called
double dispatch. It most of object oriented languages you're familiar with,
there's single dispatch. That is, you send a message to a particular object.
That, whatever method responds to that message, depends on what object
you're sending it to. In languages like Ada, the determination of who's going to
handle a particular message is determined not just by one argument, but by all
the arguments. Here we're looking at a situation where we're going to make that
determination on what operation we're going to apply based upon two arguments.
Second issue is, who is responsible for performing the actual traversal,
if we're talking about a compiler what we want to do is a tree walk and there
are variant, various variants of tree walks. We can place the code to perform
that tree walk in several places. We can place it in the ObjectStructure class,
in the Visitor class, or we can have some kind of Iterator object.